nous allons connaître tout de suite les
habitudes des français face au tabac des
couteaux
par jour one cigarettes seulement après
le déjeuner après le dîner et après le
petit déjeuner du matin pour quatre par
jour seulement 4,5 mais ça dépend des
jours ça dépend de mes moyens ça dépend
des circonstances
[Musique]
écoutez pas beaucoup je me disais
12 environ entre 10 et 20
ça peut déjà l'effort un bac l aucune
un paquet
bien cela varie entre
25 et 40 de près dans les 40 en moyenne
40 de paquets karam
trois paquets à environ moins quatre
paquets par jour c'est-à-dire moyenne
près de paquets par jour avez vous déjà
pensé arrêter de fumer
j'ai essayé mais je peux pas m'arrêter
quinze jours les gibiers reprendre vous
donner une explication
c'est peut-être le vice
parce que je prouve un certain plaisir à
fumer alors qu on aura ces jeux ne fera
qu est ce que vous savez que c'est aussi
bien sûr
ça ne fait rien je verrai
oprah de plus fort que moi mais j'ai
essayé puis j'y suis arrivé non parce
que je pense que ce sera assez modérée
non
non pas du tout
qui aime pas non plus et j'ai peur de
grossir
comme c'est déjà fait je pense j'ai
toujours essayé mais enfin
ne sais pas si j'arriverai quoi je sais
toujours je les fais pendant quelques
temps et puis quand j'ai le cafard je
recommence ouais pas
quoi n'est pas plus c'est tout si
j'arrive pas pourquoi c'est juste que
fumer est un jeune à partir de quel âge
avez vous fumez 14 ans ce que je peux
pour la présidence d'arrivée la patience
ouais c'est bien que c'est pour me
calmer les nerfs
ou parce que
j'ai décidé que quand j'arrêterai
j'arrête fait moi même c'est tout
j'ai essayé plus de fois mais c'est très
difficile pourquoi on qu'on arrête fait
mais on commence à manger beaucoup plus
à
certaines fois
après tout c'est très bon très dur pour
moi au besoin je me souvenais le cir
pourquoi cette figure pas dans la mesure
où c'est surtout une habitude j'ai
essayé mais
pas possible pourquoi
deuxième possible j'ai tous voulaient
arrêter vous continuez
quand même si c'est pas tout de suite
c'est une semaine après sa demande
d'augmenter tout à truyes ou une trop
grande habitude plusieurs fois oui très
souvent mais je n'ai jamais fait
et bien probablement un petit peu par
paresse je trouve que c'est agréable de
fumer et à chaque fois que j'ai une
bonne résolution c'est quand je viens
d'arrêter de fumer quand je viens de
finir une cigarette mais ça a duré
environ
cinq ou dix minutes et après je
recommence j'ai essayé je me suis
demandé pourquoi après tout je me
privais la plaisir qu'ils mettraient
grand alors j'ai recommencé et la
nocivité des cigarettes et à d'autres
choses des vapeurs d'essence
le reste aussi
vous pourrez pas empêché alors
pareil ça mais ça m'est venu à l'idée la
nocivité de la cigarette ça vous fait
pas peur non
moi ça me servirait d'avoir peur du
cancer a rien du tout pourquoi pourrions
aujourd'hui ou regardez en disant ça me
fait rien du tout
[Musique]